[Music]
so let's go to rick and i guess i'm
seven hey rick what's up brother
hey can you hear me yeah i can dude h2o
hey hey all right so i'm just shouting
out houston here
go astros i don't i don't know if
they're gonna who knows
but hey man so what's up how can i help
all right uh 45 married five kids
happily married
one kid special needs and
he's awesome
so
work
very active with the kids coach
doctor appointments parent-teacher
conference
you know
definitely you know all in cook
you know
i feel like i'm very active i think my
wife would agree
that i'm a very hands-on
always get always helping okay
my problem is
and i want to say hold on i want to do
thank you because
you your show
you taught me
what anxiety is
and how that can lead to depression yep
and so i was always thinking i was like
well i'm just a
down guy
but i was really experiencing a lot of
anxiety so i thank you for that you got
it brother thanks for listening and so i
was reading up i've been reading up on
that well anyway so
um and so i get down in the dumps
because or i get anxiety because i suck
at everything i do
um
it seems like i suck when i help out the
kids it sucks when i coach their teams
i suck at work
um
i suck when i make dinner
i uh i mean
it seems like
i when i drive the car my wife's always
correcting me
and uh
i i'm just worn out and uh i i just get
like i can't think
you know
i look to the future
and i don't get excited about anything
anymore yeah i'm just uh and i'm not
like physically worn out i'm like uh
mentally worn out
and uh and i guess i get
in what really gets me just throws me
for a loop is when like
i gotta go to like uh
you know
the latest test result on my my child's
you know cognitive disability and stuff
like that
and i just hate those yeah and i and i'm
just like you know
because during you know life you know i
run we run
we play
we goof around we go to the store
we tell jokes
and uh
and i get real
angry i guess when someone puts
uh and i get it just kills me when
someone puts a score on a piece of paper
that tells me are supposed to tell me
like
what he can't do
or what his limitations are
and um
and i i cuz and it takes me like about a
month and so what i started doing as i
started you know
and i get that it's my something's wrong
with me
and so i started writing i start writing
down my concerns and i start you know
charting them
so
like
diet and everything alcohol intake i try
to track like
is there you know what am i doing or not
doing that may
make me vulnerable to
getting down yeah
um
and so changing my diet changing
workouts and all that stuff
changing what i watch changing how much
i read
and stuff changing how much sleep i get
um but really what it is it's just
it's
i just feel like
i'm always
i'm never good enough in anything i do
yeah and i my wife would say i do a lot
yeah who told you you're not good enough
well just the feedback i mean
as much as my wife asked me to do stuff
she's all you know once i do it she's
always telling me how i should have done
it
okay um once i you know i go to work
and i feel like i got to say yes to
stuff and i do and i just i get
overwhelmed and i just
i get
it's the product i put out
i don't like it but it's like
you i have to get it done and then my
kids you know they're always
you know i didn't do this right in the
game right i i should have done this or
i didn't want to go to the doctor you
didn't tell the doctor this or
i wanted this outfit and you didn't give
me a chance and it's just like oh god
you know it's just like
hey i tell you man
it's like
i know this is horrible it's like man
you know what
maybe one day i'm just gonna like
you know get cancer or something and i
want to worry about this anymore and so
that's it and so i need tips on like
how to
constructively
you
know one i think i need to you know it's
my thinking or the way i look at the
world and i how do i
how do i hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on
number one
this is the bravest phone call i've
received in months
so
you can walk through today thinking that
you're gonna suck at everything you
didn't suck at this
okay and you've listened to this show
enough to know i don't lie to people
is the bravest phone call i've received
in a long time
and what you need right now is not
a new diet
or a new program or a couple of tips
my guess is
you are real
real lonely and you have been for a long
long time
am i right or wrong
yeah i i move around a lot so i don't i
don't get a chance to have buddies so
here's what i hear
i hear a guy
who the world is lucky to have
because you understand duty and you
understand responsibility and you've
made it your life mission to serve those
around you
and you've done all of that at the
expense of you
and when you don't have
deep rooted relationships
when nobody's ever said you know what
my life is better because of you
i'm so glad
that i get to have rick as my son
nothing in the world makes me happier
than waking up knowing that rick is my
kid
when no one says i could have married
any
yahoo god i'm so glad i chose rick
when you don't have buddies saying
that's seriously what you're gonna wear
you look like an idiot but come anyway
you're paying you're paying
or
you run to the bathroom and so someone's
paid for all the beers at the table
when you live life untethered and this
isn't a knock on you this is the world
that you were shot out of
you can chase all of the quote unquote
right things to do
down
and you get to that moment when you're
in your early 40s your late 30s and you
just say dude i'm exhausted i'm out
because you're unanchored
it's like sprinting in the pool you
don't go anywhere but you're just
running running running running
who told you as a kid
that rick sucks that's a message that
has been in your life for a long long
time
no i don't
i don't know
you know
you know what
who told me yeah i mean
i don't know maybe life you know no
no somebody either told you that hey
dude you suck or somebody never said
anything
maybe in swimming i don't know
i was trying to be a good swimmer your
folks were great
they were they did the best they could
yeah you don't they don't they don't
need you to protect them
well they were awesome
i'm not i i get i don't want to everyone
blames their parents nope
childhood we're not blaming it
all i'm doing is just trying to i want
you to see
that your moment in time right now
is a
something that you can absolutely heal
from and two
i don't want you to think it is just i
need to quit eating apples and start
eating oranges
that this is a thread that's
run through the tapestry of your life
and so let's do this don't have to talk
about your folks that's cool
but you and i both know that this threat
has been there for a minute
and you started the call by saying how
great your marriage is
it's not
and i've had seasons
where i've been in a bed with somebody
who i i know loves me
but i felt completely and totally on my
own
that's loneliness man
and you can roll your eyes and be like
bro dude it's not loneliness i just need
the right it's not i'm telling you
what's what's going on in your marriage
man
i
mean i mean i look i
i desperately love and need my wife
but
i guess
you know she's also
works got kids and
is married and
probably stresses about you know
special needs and all that stuff but
um
and so
yeah i don't really
i fee you know i i can't burden her with
you know
stuff that
she can't do anything about
brother
so i mean i don't want to bring her down
or something like you know or just
i want to bring her up listen man she
you're not going to bring her up by
making sure the trash is out
you're going to bring her up
by saying here is all of me
and when you protect her from herself
and you hide parts of yourself the parts
that are dying on the vine
the parts that are in a black hole
she feels that you're not she's not
getting the full you and you know what
she does she defaults to the things that
she knows which is nitpicking and
complaining
and nagging and reaching out that is her
broken attempt to reach across that gap
that she feels between the two of you
and she doesn't have the words to say
i'm not okay either
and so it comes out in pokes and prods
and this is and what about that and are
you serious
and
you double down with the thing that you
know which you've been told since you
were zero which is
you're not a
you're not a human being you're a human
doing
go do better
and at this point your body's saying
dude we're i'm out i can't keep doing
this
and what
i believe with all of my heart is that
y'all ran a lot you're running a life
with no margin
none and i'm not talking about financial
margin even though that may be the case
you may be stressed financially it may
be
time margin five kids is a lot in a
house especially with two working adults
that's just a lot it's a chaotic season
and then somebody throws a grenade in
the middle of your living room
which is a special needs kid which takes
extra responsibilities which everyone's
got some stupid opinion on
everyone's gonna tell you what happened
why and what you need to be doing you
should be doing that you should be doing
that
and then there's no margin there's
nowhere left to go there's no relational
cushion to fall onto
and so you both try to solve this
problem in the ways that you've tried to
solve every problem throughout your
whole life and what i'm trying to ask
you to do is this
that's not working
to try something new
and you are not a burden rick
your hurt is not a burden your
exhaustion is not a burden
it's a gift
and that's what she signed up for and
that's what you signed up for and by the
way she's burdened too
and
i'm with you man
if i
there was a season if i got one more
test or one more call on one of my kids
i was gonna lose my mind and i don't
talk about that stuff publicly
um and finally my wife and i said we
know this kid better than anybody
and we still
have support resources and all that but
i tell you what it's when we flip their
head just like you're talking about that
things did get get better and i don't
know what the disability is with your
kid that's a whole other phone call
but the key there was my wife and i were
together on that
and what
i can't recommend strongly enough dude
you sound like it like what do you do
for a living
oh engineering okay
this is gonna sound so cheesy and so
ridiculous and i'm a lifelong texan too
man so i'm i'm just speaking to the
choir here
you're a guy who solves problems
you're a guy who looks for
what is broken and you fix it and then
you move on
and what i'm telling you is this is not
a matter of something being broken
this is something different
this is something that needs healing
from the inside out and unfortunately
that healing doesn't start with
lifting heavier weights
this healing starts with you grabbing
both of your wife's hands and taking her
out somewhere and saying
i'm
exhausted and i haven't been honest with
you for a season and i don't know what
to do
well what if she doesn't know what to do
then you don't have two people that
don't know what to do that's the guy
who's trying to solve a thing to fix it
like this is an engine
and it's not
then what you do is you both
say
you both smile and go
we've got a new adventure ahead of us
and what i'll tell you is if you will
submit to that that's the word
vulnerability brother that's rolling
over and saying i could get hurt in this
but me not being honest
about how much i'm hurting
how much i'm drowning trying to keep
everybody around me happy
do you even like being an engineer have
you ever asked yourself that question
no
what do you want to do
i don't know i'm too beaten i mean i
i can't even think about that stuff
anymore
you know life happens it does
it it does
but you know what else happens rick
how come you've given up on rick
just i don't i don't think i don't think
about that i just
i i don't
i don't want my kids in 20 years calling
into a radio show like you or yours
complaining that their dad parents
didn't do this or their dad didn't do
that
i mean
that's
they won't you know they're gonna call
in they're gonna call in and say i never
knew my dad
and i always knew that dad wasn't happy
and i've spent my life trying to figure
out what what it was about me that he
wasn't happy
okay
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to be true to yourself and not in
some i'm going to quit my job and join
the theater and run away into a circus
that's what i'm talking about
the greatest gift you can give your kids
let's look at a quarterback dude the
greatest gift a quarterback can do is
sit out two games and heal his knee if
he keeps running around on the field and
saying dude i'm a quarterback i got to
be here
he plays not great
and then that knee gets worse the team
doesn't do as well and it's better for
everybody to stop for a second and get
well
and you've got to take your engineering
brain off and if you can't that's
totally fine
you got to sit down with somebody who
who doesn't have an engineering lens
who's got a healing lens
and i can hear it on you man
you know this is the right thing but you
also have 45 years of this is the way we
solve stuff
you grit your teeth and you suck it up
and you go get it done
yes
and i'm with you on that
and if you look at our country
this is year number five in a row
where we are dying younger
in the united states of america
from diseases of despair
addiction
suicide and organ disease failures like
lung disease and liver failure
we are playing a long tail suicide
in this grit your teeth and smash it and
pull yourself up and solve it is getting
us nowhere
got us a lot of really shiny toys
it's also got a generation of men just
like me and just like you and brother
i'm speaking in the choir here
i had a four-hour meeting with a doctor
this saturday this past saturday and it
was hard because he looked at my
genetics and he looked at my blood as
the most invasive blood test i've ever
been a part of i'm gonna do a special on
that in the new year on it
and he said if you continue to live like
this
it's going to be a short ride
and he was looking at my genetics i
couldn't deny him but he could look at
my blood and say you're not okay and i'm
a guy who tells people what to do for a
living
so i'm speaking to the choir here
okay
all right i need you to hear me when i
say this
you
rick are worth
having your home be a safe place you
rick
are worth a good night's sleep you worth
rick or worth
getting home and your wife gives you
that side eye dude and you know it is
going to be on
you are worth getting home and going i
don't even know
what to say to that kid and your wife
going i don't either
and you're worth a nine-year-old rolling
their eyes at you and it doesn't ruin
your soul
because you don't suck at everything i
refuse to believe that
i think you're exhausted man and i think
you're absolutely just totally alone and
i want you to solve a relationship and
that's going to start with you and your
wife
and i'm going to be real honest with you
brother i think you need to call a
counselor
and say i don't know even though i'm
here i'm an engineer i just know that
the way i'm trying to solve this puzzle
hasn't been working
and that my friend is the greatest gift
you can give your incredible five kids
and when it comes to your special needs
kid you're exactly right don't let
anybody tell your kid he's less than
he's broken he's dumb laugh take him
with you enjoy your life
raise that kid and let him know he is
loved loved loved
and accept the services that are
necessary but don't let him dictate your
life
rick this is the bravest call i've had
and i'm grateful for you
i challenge i dare you to take your wife
out hold your hands look across the
table and say i'm exhausted and i'm
sorry i don't know what to do next i
dare you to go call a counselor in
houston and say i need some help
i dare you to take my friend ken
coleman's in fact we'll send it to you
for free
his
career his career assessment what do you
actually want to do man
and by the way my mom started going to
college she was four in her 40s
and became a professor in the back half
of her life dude you're halfway done man
you got halfway to go
our community our kids everybody needs
you man and you're worth it
step into it